there's been an awakening have you felt
it
the dog side delight
hey youtubers is Charlie I hope all your
brains had just melted but this is gonna
be my breakdown of the Star Wars footage
so I'm also announcing the winner of my
first weekly Star Wars giveaway is just
an Amazon gift card all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
about comments on this video so the
first thing is the voiceover I know it
sounds like Benedict Cumberbatch but I
think it's Max von Sydow we only see a
couple of the cast members but it's all
about the new force sensitive characters
waking up to the force like Luke
Skywalker in Episode four which is funny
because John boyega here looks like he's
a stormtrooper on Tatooine looking for
that soccer ball droid these are not the
droids you're looking for
it also implies that he's one of the
good characters I like the idea that
someone from the empire is going to
become a good Jedi and it makes it
possible that someone from the good guys
one of the rebels is going to wake up to
the dark side of the force this Dark
Jedi at the end of the trailer with the
lightsaber also probably one of the new
younger cast members but I don't think
we're gonna find out who it is until we
get more footage definitely not till
right before the film they might even
hold that to their best to the very end
I have seen a few of the rumors that I
think are a little bit better about the
arc of the film and who some of the
characters are I'll talk about that
during a spoilers section at the end of
this the next thing we noticed obviously
the modified John Williams score there
are special trailers and then there is
this normally trailer music is taken
from finished cuts of the film or just
general stock bringing Star Wars back
such a huge deal that they went one step
further and had John Williams record
special music just for this trailer he's
scoring the entire film but the trailer
music is just a one-off thing
like it's just a slightly modified
version of his original score it's
basically the same cue from Luke
Skywalker getting ready to jump into the
Sarlacc pit from Return of the Jedi so
just think of this is like Sarlacc pit
music I like that implication that the
new movie is like the Sarlacc pit we're
getting ready to jump into the mouth of
new Star Wars films and slowly be
digested over the course of like the
next six or seven years here's a pretty
awesome shot inside an imperial troop
transport the stormtrooper helmets look
just like the concept art that leaked
earlier this year I think the reason
they changed this is just to account for
30 years of innovation and to make them
look a little bit more practical just
more streamlined they even updated the
blaster rifles here look how shiny ooh a
lot of this I think is just to make it
pop on screen the old ones were this
dull black color you know of course
they're totally gonna be selling all
this stuff as toys before the movie
comes out it's gonna be a very shut up
and take my money
situation here's another one of the new
cast members this is Daisy Ridley also
lot of rumors about her character who
she's playing the implication that she's
one of the rebels like she's one of the
good guys the x-wings we've already seen
you know along with the helmets and the
uniforms also slightly modified just a
pop a little bit more on-screen just
like the stormtroopers and again the
change in the design and the ship's
pride just account for 30 years of
innovation I can't tell which planet is
there specifically that they're flying
on they spent a lot of time in the movie
filming on a lake that was doubling as a
very famous planet that we haven't seen
in the movies yet if it's a trap rings
any bells
just think in that direction but it
really the clip clears up any questions
about what the relationship of the
Empire and the rebellion are you know
both relatively intact still fighting
against each other I don't know how
they're gonna explain the aftermath of
the Battle of Yavin but it seems like in
this timeline that was not like the huge
blow to the Empire that it was in the
expanded universe like the period after
when the throng novels started to pick
up was kind of the beginning of the New
Republic era and yes there there won't
be any new republic in the new trilogy
it'll still be Empire versus rebellion
then we get to this really interesting
part with the Sith Warrior we don't know
which planet this is but really it's the
lightsaber we need to talk about the new
rebels cartoon series also introduced a
lightly modified lightsaber with the
Inquisitor since episode 7 something of
the beginning of new force sensitive
characters I don't think we're gonna be
seeing a whole ton of Dark Jedi with
modified sabers Darth Maul Rula - he had
the double hilt so this might just be
the latest affectation I actually think
is really cool I mean it definitely
invokes imagery but like a traditional
broadsword and the updated CG on the
energy blade makes it look like it
almost has trails of fire spitting out
that's actually what drew my attention
the most it just it makes the lightsaber
seem like a much more violent weapon
less like a big glow stick which is kind
of funny if you know how they did the
effects for the original lightsaber just
look like the spinning motors in the
mirrors Millennium Falcon of course
looking badass as always notice that
they've finally repaired the deflector
dish that's actually the most notable
thing to me aside from the fact that
it's flying around in the atmosphere of
what looks like Tatooine I think there
are a couple reasons they included this
shot you know one because it looks cool
against the blue sky background and two
it's a little more scientifically
accurate the way it's maneuvering inside
atmosphere versus space the original
trilogy was criticized a little bit for
the way it portrayed
battles one of the few series I've seen
that tried to do accurate space battles
and with the way physics are and the way
ships move around in space is Battlestar
Galactica the Ronald D Moore series so
it just looks a little bit cooler flying
around in Tatooine atmosphere and it's
scientifically accurate plus they can
add these little air trails here
the TIE fighters is fighting look
relatively the same and all the sound
effects also sound the same if you've
been watching the new rebel series like
they use all the classic sounds just
like they should be it would be
blasphemous if they didn't just to talk
about you know new trailers new footage
they'll probably be showing off the
first full trailer at celebration next
year as like a convention exclusive and
then they'll totally post it online I
know everyone wants something special
for Star Wars day on May the fourth -
since that's so close to Avengers 2
being released Disney will definitely
take advantage of that I mean overall
the big takeaway from all this is just
the tactile look of the universe JJ
Abrams made this big deal to do as much
real creature and practical effects as
possible don't be fooled though I mean
there's still gonna be a shitload of CG
but because it's so good now they can
use it to make it look like the dirty
lived-in steampunky original trilogy
overall I'm not really expecting to get
any official information about the
characters at least until celebration
but that's only a couple months away so
we might learn about a few of the
characters Disney's keeping as much of
this as close to the vest as possible
which I totally love I mean never again
are we going to go into a new Star Wars
film knowing absolutely zero about the
characters in the story it's just gonna
be a little bit more exciting I think by
the time we get to Episode 8 9 we'll
know who some of the characters are
we'll kind of know what the story is the
movie itself is gonna be out December
18th next year
Star Wars itself is moving from like a
spring franchise to winter so all these
films are gonna be winter films so now
I'm gonna talk just a little bit about a
couple of the rumors about the film so
far these are all rumors but I'm still
gonna put this spoiler tag up just while
I'm talking about it just in case so
here we go so talking about rumors first
is Star Wars rebels supposedly that's
only gonna run for a couple more seasons
it's already been greenlit for season
two but after that ends its run we're
gonna get a new cartoon series that will
run concurrently with the new trilogy so
we'll have a cartoon that'll take place
while the new films are taking place I'm
really excited about that I mean I love
rebels it's a lot of fun even though
a little bit harder for me to get videos
out just because there's so many other
things happening right now but hopefully
it's celebration they'll make some sort
of announcement about that new cartoon
series talking about episode 7 rumors
though the biggest is is that this is
gonna be a film all about the force
itself about the cosmic force as well as
midi-chlorians and the way people
connect to the force like the multiple
of different aspects of the force itself
like imagine a whole film where the
force itself is the main character
supposedly the idea is that in the wake
of episode 6 Luke Skywalker becomes the
sole receptacle for the force not in
like a literal sense but it starts to
drive him mad he starts to get crazy
visions like Paul Atreides Leto tradies
God Emperor dune type style and kind of
goes off into seclusion and so the whole
movie like the protagonists and the
empire are looking for him the other
really big rumor is that supposedly one
of the good characters like someone he
knows might be related to is going to
wake up to the dark side of the force
and he's going to try and take them down
because of future visions as he has it's
like a sort of reverse original trilogy
arc whereby he learns about a new
character like a new child waking up to
the darkside might become a dark Jedi's
so it puts the heroes it puts like the
original cast members in opposition to
each other just a little bit again just
a rumor but pretty big rumor really I'm
mostly excited about the idea of them
deepening the lore of the force if you
watch Clone Wars season 6 as well as the
lost missions they get a lot into force
lore so it's actually pretty exciting if
you haven't you should totally check
those out congratulations to the winners
of my first weekly Star Wars giveaway
Destinee McDonald and Nathan H please
contact me on my channel for details
I just need some communication infos so
I know where to send the gift cards to
you both went $20 Amazon gift cards and
again I'm just going to be doing a
weekly Star Wars giveaway all you have
to do to enter that is be a subscriber
leave a comment I'll just announce new
winners every time I post a new Star
Wars bonus video and again since I'll be
doing bonus movie videos feel free to
leave requests in the comments below
just a quick reminder new mobile links
up here in case you're on your mobile
phone you can just click it's the same
as the links that I over here but click
here for all my Star Wars bonus videos
and click here to learn all about the
new Game of Thrones telltale game that's
coming out next week thank you so much
for watching that's all
I will see you guys tomorrow me me me me